ya hemos hablado en varios vídeos acerca
de gráficas como la que vemos aquí esta
es la gráfica de una empresa en
particular una que está en la industria
de las zonas y podemos ver como el costo
marginal se relaciona con el costo total
medio y el costo variable medio esto lo
analizamos con mayor detalle en vídeos
anteriores pero podemos ver la tendencia
del costo marginal que al inicio va
disminuyendo porque conforme aumenta la
cantidad cada unidad adicional se
beneficia de cosas como la
especialización y después el costo
marginal o el costo de producir una
unidad adicional como una función de la
cantidad aumenta por cuestiones como los
costos de coordinación también vimos
como esto se relaciona con el costo
variable medio ya que mientras el costo
marginal sea menor al costo variable
medio cada unidad adicional va a
disminuir el costo variable medio pero
cuando el costo marginal cruza el costo
variable medio cada unidad adicional va
a aumentar el costo variable medio lo
mismo ocurre cuando cruza el costo total
medio y por supuesto la diferencia para
cierta cantidad entre el costo total
y el costo variable medio será el costo
fijo medio teniendo esto en mente ahora
vamos a pensar cómo esta empresa va a
reaccionar bajo diferentes condiciones
del mercado vamos a suponer que esta
empresa se encuentra en un mercado muy
competitivo o mejor dicho en un mercado
de competencia perfecta por lo que la
empresa es precio aceptante primero
imaginemos un escenario positivo para
esta empresa imaginemos que el precio
está aquí arriba vamos a llamarle peso 1
y en un vídeo anterior mencionamos que
sería razonable para una empresa que
busca maximizar su ganancia producir
cierta cantidad en la que coincidan el
costo marginal y el ingreso marginal si
hablamos de un mercado competitivo
entonces este precio de aquí no está en
función de la cantidad producida por la
empresa es por eso que es una recta
horizontal y será lo mismo que el
ingreso marginal en esta situación para
peso 1 la empresa producirá la cantidad
que sube 1 esta es una buena situación
para la empresa porque el precio que
obtiene es mayor que el costo total
medio de manera que esta empresa
obtendrá una buena cantidad de ganancias
la ganancia será el precio menos el
costo total medio en esa cantidad
multiplicada por dicha cantidad debido a
que uno es mayor que el costo total
medio la situación para la empresa es
rentable y querrá permanecer en el
mercado pero como tenemos una empresa
rentable en el mercado y posiblemente ya
existen varias empresas rentables en ese
mercado es probable que atraiga a
entrantes ya que otras empresas pueden
decir que también quieren tener tanto
dinero como esta empresa de donas de
aquí por lo que es probable que hayan
más empresas que quieran entrar a este
mercado lo que quizá disminuya a este
precio ahora quizá disminuyan los
precios hasta que se llegue a un precio
que se vea así que llamaremos p sub 2 en
este escenario una empresa que quiere
maximizar su ganancia seguirá
produciendo hasta que el costo marginal
sea igual al ingreso marginal que en
este caso es el precio que será la
cantidad q sub 2
en este escenario p sub 2 es igual al
costo total medio por lo que la empresa
rompe la capacidad de producir con
ganancia no tiene ni pérdida a mi
ganancia
en este caso la empresa es neutral con
respecto a si se queda en el mercado a
largo plazo o si sale del mercado pero
es muy probable que ya no atraiga
entrantes pero tiene sentido para la
empresa seguir operando en esta
situación aún a largo plazo porque al
menos está en equilibrio ahora
imaginemos otro escenario en este caso
el precio está en este nivel por
cualquier razón el precio del mercado
bajó hasta acá y como ya mencionamos
cualquier empresa razonable va a
producir hasta q sub 3 donde el costo
marginal es igual al ingreso marginal en
pesos 3 ocurre en cosas interesantes
porque peso 3 es menor que el costo
total medio por lo que la empresa tiene
pérdidas es decir que la empresa no es
rentable y probablemente se pregunten
qué es lo que hará la empresa en esta
situación
simplemente cerrará a corto plazo no
tiene sentido que la empresa cierre ya
que el precio que obtiene aún es mayor
que su costo variable medio a corto
plazo los costos fijos ya fueron pagados
por lo que tiene sentido obtener la
mayor ganancia adicional marginal que se
pueda mientras el precio sea mayor al
costo variable medio
sin tomar en cuenta sus costos fijos la
empresa seguirá recibiendo algo de
dinero que puede compensar esos costos
fijos así que aquí suceden dos cosas la
empresa siguió operando a corto plazo
pero qué hará a largo plazo a largo
plazo no tiene sentido seguir en un
mercado en el que no se pueden obtener
ganancias así que saldrá del mercado a
largo plazo en general la terminología
que se usa cuando las personas hablan de
iniciar o parar a corto plazo es el de
cerrar o seguir operando a corto plazo y
cuando se trata a largo plazo cuando se
van a vender las fábricas o a
desmantelarse o si se van a crear nuevas
fábricas se refiere cómo salir o entrar
a la industria y por supuesto tenemos
una situación aún peor que está para la
empresa cuando el precio está hasta acá
abajo le llamamos peso 4 aquí en teoría
cuando se intersecta el costo marginal q
sub 4 no tiene sentido que la empresa
siga operando en lo absoluto debido a
que pesó 4 es menor que el costo total
medio la empresa va a querer salir del
mercado a largo plazo
en esta situación no vamos a esperar
tanto tiempo para vender las fábricas
porque peso 4 es menor al costo variable
medio por lo que vamos a cerrar a corto
plazo en resumen desde el punto de vista
de la empresa obviamente se quiere estar
en el escenario de peso 1 en donde se
obtiene una ganancia pero se pueden
atraer entrantes en peso 2 la empresa es
neutral acerca de salir o entrar al
mercado a largo plazo oa que otras
empresas entren al mercado en este
escenario se está en equilibrio pero se
rompe la capacidad de producir con
ganancia en peso 3 a largo plazo la
empresa va a querer salir porque no se
obtienen ganancias ya que si el precio
permanece en ps3 este precio es menor al
costo total medio en la cantidad
razonable a producir así que la empresa
sale a largo plazo pero debido a que ps3
es mayor al costo variable medio en la
cantidad razonable la empresa seguirá
operando a corto plazo en el último
escenario el precio peso 4 es tan bajo
que ya no tiene sentido seguir operando
ni un momento más con esto terminamos y
nos vemos
el siguiente vídeo